problem 143
143
3.003
divided by
2.002 is equal to this already looks
suspicious i mean it looks like 3 over 2
and but just to just to confirm that
let's see this is the same thing as 3
times what
1.001
yeah
and this is the same thing as 2 times
2 times
1.001 so you cancel those out and yeah
you get 3 over 2 which is the same thing
as 1.5
and that's choice e
problem
144
if
4
minus x
over
2
plus x
is equal to x
what is the value of
x squared
plus 3 x
minus 4.
let's see if we could simplify this a
little bit let's multiply both sides of
this equation times 2 plus x so you get
4
minus x is equal to two plus x times x
is two x
plus x squared
let's subtract
let's subtract uh
x from both no add x to both sides you
get four
is equal to
three x plus x squared subtract four
from both sides
and you get
zero is equal to minus four plus three x
plus x squared which is just rearranging
that which is the same thing as x
squared plus three x
minus four so that is equal to zero
which is c
c
next problem one forty five
145
all right they've drawn us a trapezoid
let me see if i can draw the trapezoid
as well
so they have the base
one side
and then they have another side
something like that and they connect
two lines like that
and then they label this side as two
feet
this side is 5 feet
and they say this is a and this is b
all right
the trapezoid shown in the figure above
represents a cross section of the rudder
of a ship
if the distance from a to b is 13 feet
so they're saying the distance from a to
b is 13 feet that distance is 13
13 feet what is the area of the cross
section of the rudder in feet
so let's think about this a little bit
let's see if we can figure out this area
so
let me see if i could draw
so if we can figure out
let me see
so this area right here is easy to
figure out well let's see if this is 13
this is 5
what is this side going to be equal to
we can use pythagorean theorem if we
call this x we could say
x squared plus this side squared plus 25
is equal to 13 squared 13 squared is
what 169 i want to say that but let me
check i haven't memorized my 13 times
tables 3 times 13 is 39
130 yeah 169
169 equals 169
subtract 25 from both sides you get x
squared is equal to
144
that tells us we're on the right track
we got a perfect square so x is equal to
12.
so let's see it's very easy to figure
out the area of of this part of the
triangle of this part of the trapezoid
right it's just the base times the
height times one-half
right base times so would be you know 12
times 5 which is 60 times one half so
this would be 30 this area here but this
is a little bit trickier
let's think about it this way what if we
were to let's
let's
extend this trapezoid into a rectangle
right
so if you did that then you can view the
area of the rudder so the original
problem what i have in magenta there as
the area of this entire rectangle
minus and let me do it in a
minus this green area right here
right
so let's do that well what's what's
first of all what's the area of this
green area
so this side is what
this side this if this is two this side
is three and we already figured out this
width is twelve so the green area is 3
times 12 times 1 half right that's the
area of a triangle
so 3 times 12 is 36 times one half is 18
we're doing different color so the area
of this green area is 18. so the area of
our rudder
the area of our rudder this whole
magenta area that i'm shading in is
equal to the area of the triangle sorry
the area of the rectangle minus 18. so
the area of the rectangle is 12 times 5
which is 60
and then let's subtract out the green
area minus 18 is equal to 60 minus 10
that's what 42
42 and that's choice c
problem 146.
one hundred forty six
if
zero
is less than or equal to
x which is less than or equal to four
and y
is less than 12.
which of the following cannot be the
value of x y
of x y so let's look at let me write
down all the choices
a
minus two
and y is less than 12 i don't see why
not x could be
x could be 2 and
y could be
minus 1 right y could be arbitrarily
small so that you know that it's not
true it's not a
b
zero
well x and y actually can both be zero
so if you multiply i'm no reason why you
can't get zero
c
six
six well if x is 2
and y is 3 i can easily get 6. and they
don't even tell us that x and y have to
be different
d and they don't even tell us they have
to be integers 24.
so if i'm
well the the largest number that x
can be equal to
is 4
right and x can't be negative so if x is
4
times y is 6
you get 24. so i'm already guessing that
the answer is e without having looked at
it
e 48
right because the largest value of x is
4
and so you would have to multiply 4
times 12 to get to 48 but you can't get
there
right so the answer is
e
problem
147
turn the page
140 so i'll do it in blue since it seems
to be dealing with water
147 and the figure above let me draw the
figure above
so i have a
v axis and then i have this other axis
and then they've drawn
some what looks like water at least
before reading the problem
drawn that
they say this is v
they say that this this distance
is five feet
they say that this distance
is 10 feet
and they label us a couple of points
it's r
and that's
s all right in the figure above
v represents an observation point
an observation point at one end of a
pool
from v an object that is actually
located on the bottom of the pool at
point r so an object that is actually
here
appears to be at point s
okay so it's kind of like the light
right so the light goes from here but
then reflects and goes like that so if
you just follow the path it would go
straight to point s
if v r
is equal to 10 feet
what if v r is oh v r is equal to 10
feet so let me draw vr
v
r
vr is equal to 10 feet
10 feet what is the different distance
rs in feet between the actual position
between the actual position and the
perceived position of the object
so they want to know this distance right
here
well let's think about it a little bit
we know if we can figure out this
distance
we can figure out this distance that we
subtract that that distance from 10
we'll have this distance
so what's this let's call this x
this is a right triangle
so you have
x squared plus
5 squared plus 25
is equal to this hypotenuse squared is
equal to 100 just pythagorean theorem
x squared is equal to
75
so then x
is going to be equal to z square root of
75
that's someplace between 8 and 9 right
8 is 64.
9 is 81. so x is
greater than 8 and less than 9.
i don't know actually they write it in
terms of square root of
so let me simplify this a little bit
more so i can write that as square root
of 75 i can write as 3 times 25
square root of 25 is 5. so that becomes
5 square roots of 3.
so this distance right here is 5 square
roots of 3.
so if i want to figure out this distance
i just subtract that from 10. so 10
minus 5 square roots of 3
and that is choice a
see in the next video